este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
blind keys seguro que al igual que a mí
muchas veces tienes la sensación de que
no le es tanto como te gustaría que si
exámenes trabajo una nueva serie al
final siempre hay algo que sacaba
interponiendo o de equívoco bueno pues
que me dirías si te dijera que existe
una app que te resume en 15 minutos
miles de libros de no ficción en inglés
de todo tipo pues amigos es app existe y
se llama blind keys y no sólo podrás
encontrar libros en formato de texto
sino también en formato de audio que oye
por un lado nunca viene mal hacer oído y
por otro siempre te da más libertad para
por ejemplo escucharlo mientras vas en
el metro mirad una de las cosas que más
nos habéis preguntar siempre en visual
político es que os recomendamos libros
pues precisamente en blind keys
encontraréis muchos de los que siempre
os decimos allí encontraréis apuestas
seguras como por ejemplo fax bulnes
freakonomics o porque fracasan los
países después presta atención los
primeros 100 de vosotros que vayáis a
brink east puntocom barra vp tendréis
acceso ilimitado por una semana para
aprobar blink y totalmente gratis si no
os convence podéis cancelarlo sin
problema durante esos siete días y en
caso de que os guste disfrutaréis
también además de un 25 por ciento de
descuento para un full membership
gracias a blind keys por ofrecer esta
oportunidad a la comunidad visual
política y por apoyar nuestro proyecto y
sin más arranquemos
[Aplausos]
un momento porque tenemos algo que
presentaros por visual política han
desfilado ya vladimir putin y donald
trump así que ahora nos tocaba cambiar
de continente estáis preparados para la
nueva entrada pues allá vamos
[Música]
el 2020 coincidió en el calendario
astrológico chino con el año de la rata
un tiempo que según los astrólogos
chinos vendría cargado de oportunidades
abundancia y prosperidad sin embargo por
mucho año de la rata que fuese las cosas
empezaron de mal en peor la persistencia
de la guerra comercial y sobre todo la
pandemia del sars coronavirus 2 pusieron
en jaque la economía china ya en febrero
del 2020 todas las previsiones apuntaban
a que el gigante asiático el país de los
tres reyes tendría que enfrentarse a una
enorme tormenta una marejada todo un
huracán económico y no sólo eso durante
el 2020 también hemos visto la que tal
vez ha sido la cara más agresiva y
nacionalista de china de las últimas
décadas y si pensáis que exagero no
tenéis más que recordar los hechos
atentos
[Música]
durante el año de la rata china aplastó
las libertades políticas de hong kong
intensificó su presión sobre taiwán
alimentó aún más lo que ya se ha venido
a conocer como la nueva guerra fría
contra los eeuu desató una enorme ola de
represión en xinjiang contra la minoría
uigur mcdow tropas a la frontera con la
india y lanzó una operación de castigo
comercial contra australia por haberse
atrevido este país a pedir una
investigación serie sobre el origen del
sars coronavirus 2 e incluso durante
este mismo año china también aprobó una
nueva ley de control de las
exportaciones una ley por la cual las
exportaciones de ciertos productos
considerados como estratégicos requiere
de la aprobación expresa del gobierno
hablamos de exportaciones como por
ejemplo los minerales conocidos como las
tierras raras pero claro los productos
considerados estratégicos son
arbitrariamente escogidos por el
gobierno así que podrían incluir
cualquier cosa que se les pasará por la
cabeza en esta lista es decir para que
nos entendamos esta nueva ley no es ni
más ni menos que una nueva arma que
china podría emplear ante una guerra
comercial o campaña de presión política
en fin creo que no está nada mal para
tan sólo un año no os parece
e
desde luego nadie podrá decir que los
líderes chinos se echaron a dormir
aunque no fuese precisamente para hacer
las cosas de cosas que nos gustaría
contaros el caso es que lógicamente
todas estas acciones llevadas a cabo por
el gobierno de sillín ping no sólo han
recibido enormes cantidades de críticas
y condenas sino que también han
incrementado por ejemplo los riesgos
geopolíticos de invertir en el gran
gigante asiático además de hundir su
imagen a lo largo y ancho de todo el
planeta especialmente entre los países
desarrollados la imagen desfavorable de
china alcanza máximos históricos en
muchos países pues bien el caso es que
entre la guerra comercial el coronavirus
el hundimiento reputacional y todas las
cosas que hemos visto llevó a cabo china
durante el año pasado la abundancia y la
prosperidad prometida por el año de la
rata parecía un pronóstico más cerrado
que el de steve balmer antiguo señor de
microsoft cuando dijo aquello de que el
iphone no tenía ninguna posibilidad de
triunfar
sin embargo esperar un momento porque al
final en el caso de china las cosas
fueron muy pero que muy diferentes y en
2020 incluso terminó así la economía de
china se expande a un ritmo más rápido
que antes de coronavirus el pib e
aumenta un 6,5 por ciento en el cuarto
trimestre del 2020 mientras otras
grandes economías luchan por recuperarse
de la pandemia y claro visto lo visto en
el resto del mundo
la pregunta la gran pregunta que todos
podemos hacernos es qué demonio ha
pasado con china pues queridos amigos
amigas lo cierto es que contra viento y
marea a pesar de todo y aunque pueda
sorprender temas que tesla presentando
un coche movido por diésel 2020 fue uno
de los años en los que siguen ping
cosechó más éxitos desde que está en el
poder y ojo que no sólo hablamos de su
campaña nacionalista atentos porque está
que os vamos a contar es la historia de
cómo sí jinping le infligió durante el
2020 una dura derrota a la gran potencia
norteamericana los eeuu de américa
comencemos
[Música]
contra viento y marea vale puede
resultar completamente chocante pero si
hablamos de política y economía china
terminó el año del cob y bastante más
fuerte de lo que lo arrancó el gigante
asiático fue una de las pocas economías
importantes que terminaron el año con
crecimiento económico positivo reforzó
su papel en el comercio mundial y
apuntaló su papel como la fábrica del
mundo tal vez el hecho más
representativo de esta evolución es que
mientras que medio mundo las economías
colapsaban ante el avance del
coronavirus en diciembre del 2020 china
anunció la erradicación de la pobreza
extrema en su territorio y amigos en
esta ocasión los expertos apuntan a que
este hecho no tiene por qué ser una
exageración del gobierno en chinas sigue
habiendo pobres claro pero según el
banco mundial durante las últimas cuatro
décadas nada menos que 800 millones de
chinos han abandonado la pobreza y ahora
según el gobierno chino ya no existen
bolsas de pobreza extrema en todo el
país un logro enorme si tenemos en
cuenta
178 poco después del fallecimiento de
máó la inmensa mayor parte de los chinos
vivían en condiciones de pobreza extrema
china fue el país donde surgió el sars
coronavirus 2 y por tanto fue el primer
país golpeado por la pandemia durante
los dos primeros meses del 2020 vimos
imágenes tremendas de como lakovic 19
estaba causando estragos de la misma
forma que también vimos una respuesta
muy pero que muy contundente por parte
del gobierno chino
los primeros confinamientos y
probablemente las medidas de
erradicación del coronavirus más duras
de todo el mundo se pusieron en marcha
aquí y el resultado es que el gobierno
chino no sólo consiguió frenar por
completo la propagación del coronavirus
sino que a pesar del duro golpe recibido
por caídas históricas de la producción
económica logró aquí si toda una
recuperación en v
un apunte ya sabéis porque os lo hemos
contado que los datos oficiales
presentan más dudas que las tesis
doctorales y los títulos de máster los
políticos de españa sin embargo en esta
ocasión todos los datos alternativos que
se utilizan para cotejar la veracidad de
los datos oficiales como por ejemplo la
evolución de los préstamos bancarios la
producción de electricidad la actividad
en los puertos las exportaciones a china
del resto de países etcétera etcétera
apuntan en la misma dirección la
economía china cerró 2020 a pleno
rendimiento
[Música]
en esta misma línea por ejemplo mientras
que la inversión extranjera directa se
desplomó durante buena parte del 2020 en
eeuu y europa
en china apenas se resintió entre enero
y noviembre se incrementó más de un 6%
respecto al año anterior de hecho con
los datos en la mano lo que vimos en
2020 es la clara manifestación de cómo
los eeuu han perdido estrepitosamente la
guerra comercial queridos amigos corría
el año 2018 cuando donald trump escribió
esto en twitter cuando un país eeuu
pierde muchos miles de millones de
dólares en el comercio con prácticamente
todos los países con los que hace
negocios las guerras comerciales son
buenas y fáciles de ganar
donald trump en twitter claro que la
historia desde entonces ha sido muy
diferente
washington se lanzó a toda una bacanal
de aranceles y barrera al comercio de
todo tipo pero los resultados no han
sido los esperados
mientras el déficit comercial de la
potencia norteamericana ha continuado
batiendo récords en 2020 el peso de
china en el comercio mundial apenas ha
resentido e incluso en 2020 el peso de
las exportaciones chinas en las
exportaciones globales ha superado la
cifra previa de la guerra comercial de
hecho al final durante el año de la rata
el gigante asiático logró el segundo
mayor superávit comercial de toda su
historia más de 535 millones de dólares
la demanda de productos chinos es tan
fuerte que ahora el problema es que no
hay suficiente capacidad de los puertos
en otras palabras los enormes esfuerzos
norteamericanos que han castigado a sus
consumidores empresas y productores no
han valido prácticamente de nada y eso
ni siquiera es todo para colmo el año de
la pandemia constató que a pesar de todo
el gigante asiático sigue siendo la
fábrica más fiable de todo el planeta
[Música]
fijaos tras erradicar el coronavirus la
actividad industrial se restableció
totalmente y mientras las cadenas de
producción de muchos países sufrían
problemas de abastecimiento en china
cualquier empresa tenía prácticamente a
cualquier proveedor que necesitara
trabajando a pleno rendimiento de hecho
si algo ha dejado claro el 2020 es que
este efecto red es simple y llanamente
una ventaja enorme y eso eso es
exactamente lo que explica cosas como
estas
[Música]
una encuesta del banco de inversión hsbc
realizada en noviembre entre más de 1100
corporaciones globales mostró que ni más
ni menos el 75 por ciento de las grandes
empresas industriales esperan
incrementar sus inversiones directas en
china incluyendo el 70 por ciento de las
empresas estadounidenses
[Música]
lo siento pero los números son
contundentes el pulso librado entre
donald trump y xi jinping lo ha ganado
de forma aplastante el líder chino claro
que esta no ha sido ni mucho menos única
victoria en 2020 atentos al cambio de
juego global que se está produciendo
[Música]
la mejor partida de xi jinping
el 15 de noviembre se anunció un acuerdo
histórico y quizás la mayor victoria
política de xi jinping es el día 15 de
noviembre 15 países de la región
asia-pacífico incluyendo a los tres
gigantes económicos china japón y corea
del sur firmaron el conocido como
acuerdo de asociación económica integral
regional el bloque comercial con mucha
diferencia más grande de todo el planeta
un bloque que abarca a más de 2.300
millones de personas y el 30 por ciento
de toda la economía mundial hablamos de
un tratado que según las estimaciones va
a impulsar el comercio regional en
cientos y cientos de miles de millones
de dólares al tiempo que ordenará bajo
reglas y normas comunes no sólo el
comercio de bienes y servicios sino
también la inversión transfronteriza y
el comercio electrónico de toda la
región una región que se ha convertido
ya en el epicentro económico del mundo
[Música]
y amigos por supuesto tal y como os
podéis imaginar china está en el corazón
de todo este acuerdo el comercio entre
asiático que ya es más grande que el
comercio de asia con américa del norte y
europa juntas continuará impulsando el
crecimiento económico global y
desplazando el centro de gravedad
económico hacia asia stuart aid jefe
regional de banca comercial para
asia-pacífico del hsbc amigos si nada
más llegar al poder donald trump decidió
sacar a eeuu del pp en ese mismo momento
china pisó el acelerador para lograr su
propio acuerdo un además mucho más
grande un acuerdo que no sólo va a
impulsar la economía china sino que
también va a hacer que poco a poco
muchos de los principales aliados eeuu
se integren cada vez más con el gigante
chino por ejemplo por este acuerdo el 86
por ciento de las exportaciones
japonesas a china quedarán libres de
aranceles y en el caso de corea del sur
esta cifra se elevará hasta más del 90
por ciento así que ya lo veis aunque el
nuevo presidente norteamericano joe
biden decida incorporarse al pp ahora el
predominio norteamericano en la región y
su capacidad de influir
ya no será ni mucho menos lo mismo
para colmo pocos días después de la
firma de este acuerdo el propio xi
jinping manifestó la posibilidad de que
china solicitar adherirse al propio pp
lo que supondría todo un quebradero de
cabeza en washington y le daría a china
la posibilidad de liderar los dos
mayores acuerdos comerciales del mundo
al tiempo que eeuu no formaría parte de
ninguno de ellos
[Música]
pero amigos esta cura de los quince no
fue la única buena noticia que tuvo en
2020 la estrategia diplomática del líder
chino la noche del 30 de diciembre se
anunció que china y la unión europea
habían alcanzado tras más de seis años
de negociaciones un acuerdo de inversión
un acuerdo que facilitará las
inversiones de muchas empresas europeas
en algunos sectores de china como por
ejemplo en el sector del automóvil que
dicho de paso es clave para para sabéis
quién exactamente a alemania volkswagen
invierte más de 2 mil millones de
dólares en la industria de automóviles
eléctricos de china el fabricante de
automóviles alemán aumenta su
participación en una empresa conjunta
china de vehículos eléctricos y comprar
una participación en un productor de
baterías pero hablamos de un acuerdo que
sobre todo supone una bofetada
diplomática a la nueva administración de
joe biden porque
pues porque el nuevo presidente de los
eeuu de la mano de su asesor de
seguridad nacional
jake sullivan le había pedido a la
europea que no rubricar a ese pacto y
que desde ahora formase en sociedad esos
acuerdos con china es decir en vez de
negociar cada uno por libre negociar
conjuntamente y decirle a xi jinping hay
si ojo que estás hablando con el 40% de
la economía mundial sin embargo pues
bueno el momento en europa han preferido
desoír la primera llamada de la nueva
administración americana tanto para
china nuevos parece el acuerdo
profundizará a los lazos económicos
entre china y la unión europea siendo la
negociación de un acuerdo de libre
comercio el siguiente paso esperado bus
symbol director del centro de estudios
americanos de la universidad de fudan en
shanghai e incluso en el orden
geopolítico actual china ha demostrado
repetidamente su voluntad de usar su
poder económico como arma estratégica al
profundizar su dependencia económica de
china sin coordinar su política con
otras democracias las naciones europeas
están aumentando su vulnerabilidad a la
presión de beijing
gideón rachman columnista del financial
times pues amigos aún hay otro campo en
el que 2020 ha sido uno
para china las finanzas
si a pesar de todos los intentos de la
administración trump durante los últimos
años la integración financiera de china
en el resto del mundo se ha disparado y
2020 no fue una excepción sino
precisamente un año bastante bueno para
los intereses chinos en este terreno
para que os hagáis una idea de lo que
estamos hablando
las tendencias extranjeras de bonos
chinos se incrementaron en 2020 un 49
por ciento respecto al año anterior y
sobre las inversiones en bolsa pues más
de lo mismo un proceso al que se están
sumando un montón de gigantes
financieros internacionales que están
desembarcando en el país asiático
gracias a las nuevas facilidades
aprobadas por el gobierno chino
es decir en otras palabras el dinero de
occidente se está lanzando a financiar
la economía china a toda velocidad
sigo creyendo firmemente que china será
una de las mayores oportunidades para
blackrock a largo plazo tanto para los
administradores de activos como para los
inversores larry fink presidente y ceo
de blackrock la empresa de gestión de
activos más grandes del mundo pero de
todo esto se hablará con todo detalle
próximamente en barrio school así que ya
sabéis no os olvidéis pasar por nuestro
canal amigo
y ya lo veis 2020 fue un año muy bueno
para los intereses de china en el mundo
ni siquiera el coronavirus o la
ocupación de hong kong han cambiado esta
realidad claro que un momento porque
todo esto no quiere decir que china
tenga el futuro del todo despejado
ojo con las malas prácticas amigos
gracias al enorme crecimiento económico
registrado durante las últimas décadas
china cuenta hoy con la segunda mayor
economía del mundo el mayor superávit
comercial las mayores reservas
financieras y hasta la marina con el
mayor número de embarcaciones militares
de todo el mundo sin embargo un momento
porque a pesar de que parece que el
gigante chino se está comiendo el mundo
el creciente autoritarismo e
intervencionismo del gobierno de xi
jinping plantea riesgos
no
desde el 2007 en la tasa de crecimiento
se ha desplomado casi a la mitad la
productividad se ha reducido la fuga de
capital humano sigue siendo importante y
la deuda circulación se ha multiplicado
por 8 especialmente en las ineficientes
empresas públicas
de esta forma aunque el crecimiento
chino parece haber sido deslumbrante si
lo comparamos con el que registraron los
famosos dragones asiáticos la cosa queda
un poquito desdibujada y esto esto nos
hace directamente hacernos una pregunta
como de cerca esta china de eeuu pero
amigos de eso lo haremos muy pronto en
un vídeo aquí en visual político así que
ya sabéis no olvidéis suscribiros al
canal si aún no lo habéis hecho y dicho
esto te paso los trastos a ti qué
opinión tienes de china cómo valora su
creciente peso internacional cómo crees
que deberían comportarse los países
occidentales déjanos las respuestas en
los comentarios y ahora si este vídeo te
resulta interesante
no olvides darle con energía al botón de
like muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]